always remember to be kind and
just courteous all hail khloe kardashian
the queen of the clap back i love it
the reality star recently posted this
pic with her adorable two-year-old
daughter true thompson that's coco
rocking a brunette bob and a bright red
lip
as true cheeses it up for the camera the
caption
mommy's baby forever i'm having so
much fun with her well that's when one
commenter
threw a little shade referencing the 36
year old's new look
asking quote who is that on the right
koko's response
your new stepmother be nice or get
grounded
bravo khloe bravo but the commenter took
the shade in stride replying simply
fair enough it is what it is i don't
take it too seriously
but this isn't the first time chloe has
snapped at a follower for commenting on
her looks
back in may the keeping up with the
kardashians star showed off a new
darker do and while friends and family
like mama kris
jenner and her beau tristan thompson
slid into the comments to complement her
new look
some of her other followers were
surprised by the pic
saying she looked unrecognizable deal
with it
chloe didn't bother responding to all
that not so nice feedback
i'm just super happy and content and i'm
focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and
true but a week later when she shared
this pic
on instagram and a fan asked her quote
why do you look so different
in all your photos chloe dropped the mic
writing
from my weekly face transplant clearly
it's not some deliberate thing that i
think that hard about and that right
there ladies and gents
that's why chloe is my favorite
kardashian
any face i have they're beautiful
you